Hi everyone.
Welcome again to today's
intro to programming webcast.
My name is Mark and to my left is-
>> My name is Jonah.
We're coaches here at Udacity.
>> I hope everyone is doing well today.
This is an August month so hopefully for
some of you it's sunny weather.
I know it's sunny weather here,
[LAUGH] in California.
>> It was raining in L.A.
>> It was pretty crazy.
>> There was flooding so.
[LAUGH] Hopefully we can get more
rain but not in the flooding kind and
more in California.
Today we're going to be talking about
the topic of planning an entire website
from front to back.
And this is a more
higher-level presentation.
We're not going to dive
too much into code.
Not too much into implementation of
this code because that deserves a whole
lecture, even a whole series
of lectures in itself.
What we're going to do is we're going to
give you an overview of the lay of
the land like the force.
We're going to show you the bigger
picture of how you start thinking
about a website and what are the things
that you need to think about and
plan for.
And these are the three things that
we're going to be really learning is
that when you walk away from this
presentation, you're going to
learn the crucial components that make
up a website and then you'll be able to
answer the big questions
involved in planning out website.
You're going to know the technologies
required in order to deliver
content to the Internet user and
you'll be able to know
how to research what technology you need
to implement after this presentation.
So basically, it's after this
presentation you'll be able to walk
away knowing on a good general
level of what needs to get done.
You, yourself as a program you may not
know everything that you need to do but
you at least know what
needs to get done and
then you'll be able to research,
get help.
Hire someone, contract out some work and
you'll be able to at least know,
at the minimum, when you're
talking with another programmer,
you could talk with them and
relay to them what you need to do.
>> That's really half to battle
is knowing what you need to do,
it's like once you have an idea
of everything you need to do and
the steps to do, executing is not nearly
as hard as figuring all that out.
So making sure that you have these
frameworks set up beforehand
makes life a lot easier later on.
>> I totally agree, and
I dare say 90% percent of
the programmer's job is just research.
>> Yeah.
>> You're just researching,
you're just figuring out how to
orchestrate and put things together.
Before we start even further let's,
we have a couple questions-
>> Yeah, [CROSSTALK] let's take a look.
>> [CROSSTALK] It's sad.
Answer Brandon's.
>> Brandon Hastings has
aa interesting question.
Will it be possible
to get this recorded?
And yes, we are currently recording.
If you're watching right now, you're
probably, it's recorded most likely.
So it will be on the Google+ page and
you can access it at any time.
It also will be put on the chorus
later at some date and
then there's a whole list of them a link
to which will be on a Google+ page.
>> Yeah,
also we'll post our transcripts and
our notes in the discussion
forums as well, so
there's there will be plenty of ways for
you to access this video recording.
>> And then we have another interesting
question, very practical question from
Cam Su Jung and they ask, in general
which job is more highly paid,
a front end developer or
backend developer?
>> That's, you can't really
answer that question because-
>> It's tough, there's so
many other variables just because you
have a skill set in front-end technology
or back end technology because depends
on how good you are as a person.
[LAUGH] Depends on how much you know and
depends on what's important for
the current company right now.
If they have an army of
back-end engineers, well, and
if they only have one and
they need one lead front-end engineer,
your position may be more valuable and
vice versa.
So it also depends on your region, too.
Where you live.
If you're talking about corporations
who need a Java back-end developer,
then they may pay a little more but
then if you'll look at a startup,
they may pay in equity,
they make pay in stock options.
So it really depends.
There is no answer to this question.
>> It's tough and I think that if you're
trying to decide between being front-end
and back-end, hopefully this
presentation should actually help you
since we're going to cover both
sides and maybe you can look and
be like, I'm a little bit
better at designing things and
understanding how users
interact with things.
Or maybe you're like, I'm a lot
better at understanding databases and
how things connect together.
Then in that case, you'd probably
want to be a back-end engineer.
So this might help you think about
which path you want to go down.
>> Yeah, and, Jobah, I like your
comment of using what you like and
what you're good at.
>> Yeah.
>> And what's your natural tendency?
And honestly, at the end of the day,
you work up to the,
and you gain enough expertise that
it's more about liking your job and
liking what you do versus
just getting paid.
>> Exactly.
>> And being good at it.
You're good at it,
you'll probably be paid better.
>> The money will follow, honestly.
If you like and you're really good
at it, the money will just follow.
But it shouldn't be just
about purely money.
>> I agree.
>> All right, let's move on.
All right, so can you screenshare?
>> Yeah, you're live.
>> All right, I'm live.
So we're going to use Prezi to present.
Yeah.
So let's just get started.
Planning a website from front to back.
Understanding the big questions
to help you plan your website.
And the first thing we need to [LAUGH]
actually really align everyone on,
I think, is to make sure that,
okay, let's align everyone and
ask ourselves, what is a website?
Well, what really is a website, Jonah?
So for most people a lot of people think
a website is just a page of information.
There's pictures and there's text.
I just put a URL, like I go to
Google.com, I go to Yahoo.com,
NewYorkTimes.com to get information and
it did and
there's a lot of magic,
magic happens and I get information.
It's like my universal library, right.
So that's what a lot
of people think about.
>> I mean back in the 90s
that what it was like.
>> It was just a way for us to
access information from the library,
but the Internet has brought so much
that it's more than static pages now.
I would like to talk line with everyone
about the definition of a website and
really, the definition that I think,
this is for me,
from a programming side,
not just like a normal user, but
it's a framework for delivering content.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Whatever we want to deliver.
Music, videos, news.
Whatever it is,
whatever information it is.
It's a framework.
It is a system.
It's a system made of a series of small,
little components that deliver
this content to our users and
that's really I want to line everyone
about this definition of website
because it makes it easy for
us this understand the components.
Of a website and
in therefore it makes us understand
the variables that's involved in
planning on making a website because
in the end, we are orchestrating.
You could think about
us as orchestrators.
We're here to orchestrate and
also in basely
link small look of components
together that deliver our website.
Let's see.
Whoops, let's go back here.
Yeah, and I'll just tell you right now.
What are the crucial
components of a website?
And these are the things that come
off the top of my head, really.
These are the main basic components,
like HTML, CSS, User Design,
JavaScript, Web Server Administration,
Databases, Caching, Server End Points.
These are all big time
components that you want to think
about when you're designing a website.
And these are the components
to actually help you deliver
the content of your website.
And really,
there's a lot of components and so
there's a lot and to help us as
programmers to categorize and
figure out okay how to
organize this information,
we often tend to put these
components into two categorize.
The front-end and the back-end.
And this is will be the most common
terminology that you will ever hear
in your web development programming
career, even programmers in general.
The front-end and the back-end, and
the front-end really involves the case
of anything that the user sees.
The browser, the design of the page,
the JavaScripting of the page,
anything that the user sees in
the browser, that's front-end design.
Like all those components such as HTML,
CSS,
User Design,
that's front-end development.
Now, there's another
side called the back-end.
And that's where no one sees.
Your users, they don't really see that.
They don't really see the servers and
the computers that's actually
pushing this information and
delivering this content to your users.
Because for back-end development
it's all about making
sure that the servers
are running correctly,
the servers can actually deliver content
to your browser to the front-end.
The back-end accesses the database and
makes sure that it
returns the appropriate
requests that the front-end or
the user will have towards our server.
So basically that's really two
categories that you really need
to think about internationalists
the front-end and back.
Well, let's see.
And now we're going to move on to the
front-end and I'm going to let Jonah to
explain more about the front and all the
components that we should think about.
>> So
the front-end is usually what you know.
As Mark said, the first thing that you
see when you're planning your website
and as such it's also the first thing
you want to start thinking about
when you're on your website.
It's the most visual component.
It's where everyone's familiar with
like is design when they
communicate with your website.
It's always through the front-end.
So you want to make sure it's clean,
it's well designed and
everything works from
the user's perspective.
So the questions you want to think about
are how are we going to lay it out?
Where are the images going to be?
Where are the techs going to be?
How is everything going to
be laid out basically.
Another thing you want to think
about is what sort of content.
So if you have a news site,
you want to think about I want to put
articles in and
videos in put maybe user responses in.
Another thing to think about is how
is he going to interact at this page.
So if it's Facebook, they're just
going to log in, they're going to
comment on their friends' posts, they're
going to like somebody's pictures.
That's what they think about when we
talk about user flow and interaction.
And then last component, I don't want to
say last because it's definitely
very important is the color and
graphic design.
And we'll talk a little bit more
about why it's important later.
So one of the most important
tools that you want to start with
before you do anything is.
These two these, two things pen paper.
You can do it on your computer,
you can design things, but
I find it's really easy to get
distracted on a computer at this stage.
So, it's best sometimes to just
grab a piece of blank paper and
start drawing things and when I talk
about trying things I mean trying boxes.
So, you talked earlier about how
HTML is all made up of boxes
their nested boxes, but everything is
laid out in these the square things.
So, what I have here,
there it is let's look
at the New York Times.
This is the average website.
You'll go to it, and it looks cool.
You have some information.
But if you look a little bit deeper,
you can see that it's actually made
up of boxes like everything else.
I use this tool called Wirify
to make this all together.
So you'll see that
the header here is a box.
The video on the front page is a box.
The article title is a box and
it's all laid out in this fashion so
that it's easy for
us to think about things abstractly.
Because it's easy to get caught
up in small details when you're
planning a website, so
you want to start big scale.
Where do I put things?
And then once you have these things you
want to think about what
goes in each of these boxes.
So the top is probably
the most important thing
that the user is going to look at.
So we put the header there
like the New York Times.
Column X.
So put the header there and
then the next thing that's probably
you're going to look at the thing
right in the middle of the page.
That's going to be like your video or
something and next you're going to
think about where you put your article.
So it's important to think about where
the user's going to look when he or
she lands on your page.
And this is sort of part of the visual
flow and you want to think about putting
the important parts central and
then auxiliary parts on the side.
So you notice that New York Times
does this really well and
it's actually based really closely on
the actual New York Times newspaper.
And that's not just because they're
trying to emulate print media.
People of thought about this before and
web design sort of has
followed in the footsteps of
print design to some extent.
So it's important think about
how you can relate to print design
when you're designing a web page, and
New York Times, I think,
is a great example of this.
So let's see.
Yeah so when you have a little bit more
complex things like popular posts,
this isn't something that you
can just put on your page.
So you have to start thinking
about what each box is going to do
in terms of the back-end.
So you can see that we're
already starting to transition
from the front-end to
the back-end at this point, and
you have to think about what sort
code each element is going to use.
So I put in HTML five for
the video right there and
that might be a way that you can
put in a video into your page.
And I'm going throw around a method or
on some terms here that you might not be
familiar with, but if you learn them as
you go through or just sort of thinking
about things in a higher level right
now and if you look at popular posts.
You can't just write out the post and
expect it to refresh automatically.
It's going to have to connect to
a database in the background so,
as you go through, make notes.
And be like okay, I have this
popular post box in the right.
I'm going to have to have it
connect to a database later on, and
I should start thinking
about how I want to do that.
and then, as far as user interaction,
you want to to put login box,
maybe somewhere where the user's
going to see it quickly.
So, the top right is a great place
that the New York Times puts it,
and then you want to think about, also,
what sort of code this is going to use?
Probably use some JavaScript, some CSS,
and then, you want to keep this in
mind as you're planning these things.
Cool.
So, the wireframing stage is really
useful for thinking about colors.
You'll see that right now,
everything's in grayscale.
And as you're writing out these boxes,
you can put things in different
shades as you put them in.
And so lighter shades will be lighter
colors, darker shades be darker colors.
And you might not think that colors are
that important and going into your page,
is like it's just cosmetic, but
the colors in the layout and the graphic
design and everything is very important,
when you're looking at a page.
When I land on a page that's
not that important and
there's bad graphic design,
I want to leave it.
So, if you have run into [CROSSTALK]
>> This is sides or
the colors are just awful.
>> Yes exactly.
So companies spend millions of dollars
sometimes redesigning their websites.
Yahoo has gone through it.
Spotify just did a redesign,
it's best to start with the good design,
so that you don't have to go back and
redesign everything, and
it makes the navigation easier, it will
make your website more pleasant to use.
It will make it more likely that people
will come back and use it later,
which is really just
the goal in the end.
So as I said, you can shape things
to make sure the contrast is good.
A good rule is to.
Group things that are similar shaded
with each other, so you'll have
dark things on the right as you say and
then the gray thing in the middle.
And then darkening the top.
And contrast is good,
it will draw your eye to it,
but you don't want to overuse contrast.
So once you have this all laid out and
you're basically done with your
wireframe, you can sort of see how
this comes together in a neat way and
at this point, you have to think about,
whether you want to design
things yourself or outsource it.
because it can take a lot of time to
do it yourself, so it might be more
valuable to ask somebody else
who's better at graphic design.
Or you might be more personally
invested in your product, so
you want to design it yourself.
How you run into having to delegate
things and do insights, or.
>> Yeah,
I'm the person who actually likes to do
>> Anything in the house.
So if sometimes fire see fire
up Adobe Illustrator to actually
design my own logo or just create
my own graphics but most are for
me, I like complete
control of my own website.
>> Absolutely,
I mean that's that's cool.
>> And if you want to have control over
it, that's that's a crucial thing for.
>> A lot of people and
then other people maybe their,
their time they want to spend it more
on making sure that the backhand works.
So, that's sort of about as much as
you can do in the front end stage and,
this will set you up
really well to do more.
Things later on.
So something else is pretty important
in front end planning is thinking
about what frameworks you might use.
So you can build a site from scratch.
You can build a New York Times
just by coding yourself,
doing every single line or make Reddit,
but there are this thing called
software frameworks and it really helps
us to speed up the development process.
Basically it takes all the things
that other people it used before, and
puts it into a prepackaged
set of code so
CSS, we have frameworks like Bootstrap,
Pure CSS, and Cascade,.
And these are sort of like prepackaged.
What are some examples of things
that frameworks can give you?
Like login buttons.
>> Login buttons
>> Color schemes
>> Color schemes, yeah.
>> [INAUDIBLE] Layouts,
that's a big thing.
>> Print
>> Yeah.
>> Responsive to the design too,
as well.
>> Definitely.
>> It's all like put the breakpoints for
like your phone tablet and.desktop,
>> Yes.
>> Its all programmed in for you.
>> Yeah, great, so Mark made a really
good point there about mobile design.
So when your programming's on on your
computer., it's easy to just get
caught up in programming things just for
the computer.
But using these frameworks like
Bootstrap helped you to think
ahead about making your website look
good on a phone or a tablet, which
is going to be huge in the coming years,
and it's already huge right now so.
>> Yeah.
I actually recommend,
if you're starting off your
career doing front end stuff like
up this nano degree, you may want to
create your own personal website.
I really recommend you just
start off mobile first.
And that's actually a big
mantra right now in
the front ended web
development communities.
So we're telling you right now,
it's all about mobile first design.
I'm starting to design
my own personal site.
>> Cool.
And it's mobile for us.
I'm actually starting with the width and
height for an iPhone 4.
I just want to say,
okay how does this look on a phone.
I'll start there, and then I'll blow up.
And it's easier for me to start small,
because I will have limited amount of
space, I need to focus on
exactly what I need to display.
>> Being efficient in space.
>> And get very efficient, and
then once I blow up, what I have I
go on to design for the desktop.
>> Yeah.
>> Ten 24 pixels then have all this
real estate then I can figure out okay,
I have all my important things.
Now what else can I add, when I blow up?
>> Right.
>> And we have a couple questions,
so let's answer these questions.
>> Yes, definitely.
>> I'm going to get to these.
S,o when you're designing
things Daniel asks.
They had to allow for
all the ads in a design.
That's good thinking.
>> It's really good actually.
>> Yeah.
>> It's a very good thinking.
Monetization is important and yeah,
thinking about where you want to
place adds is important.
You don't want to have pop ups,
What is this, 1998?.
You don't want to have banner
ads that flash at you.
You want to think about
ways to incorporate ads, so
that it's unobtrusive but still useful.
So yeah, when you're boxing
things out maybe have a box for
an ad, and just put it on the top right,
so it's still focal but
not the main focus of your site.
So yeah, think about ads,
think about monetization.
I'm using this word.
Monetization is just like how are you
going to make money from your site?
>> Easily, yeah.
>> If you're, let's say, a blog, right?
>> Yeah.
>> You're a blogger.
You want to make some money
off your hard earned work,
well the ads is actually a very
viable option for a blogger.
>> Mmm hmm.
And you know,
you don't have to sell out.
You know you can link to maybe
something that's related to your blog.
If you're doing a blog about
travel maybe you can Lead to
something that some company
that makes travel accessories.
Maybe help your readers out,
be like, yeah,
when I was traveling I used this cool
key chain that lets me charge my iPhone.
Shout out.
[LAUGH] Okay, so we have another
question here from [INAUDIBLE].
And they ask, is a full-stack developer
job scope mean that the person will
cover both front-end and
back-end job tasks?
If it is, does it mean that the
full-stack developer logically should
be more well paid?
Than the front and back-end alone?
Actually, I was thinking about this,
when you asked that question earlier.
And, that's that's still a really
difficult question to answer.
>> Still a little difficult because
a full-stack developer can never be as
good as a front-end who's just cost
trying to focus on the front-end.
And at back end person like who is just
a wizard in database administration and
looking some things up.
You can never be as good as that.
So again, it comes down to
the variability of what this company
needs now and how good are you.
And if you can say,
I could be a full-stack developer
that is amazing at front and
back, which, we started calling
them unicorns a little bit.
It's a little bit,
it's hard for a reason.
And if you feel like that, your skills
can often exceed a full front-end person
and a full back-end person,
then yeah, yeah.
>> Go for it.
You'll get paid more.
But then,
that depends on your own skill level and
your own experience not necessarily
you being a full-stack developer.
So, I do not have the statistics
to back up my claim,
I do not have any numbers to tell you,
but you can you can probably
find it on the say, US Census, if you
want to get more granular information.
>> Glassdoor probably?
>> Glassdoor.
>> They'll probably give you-
>> I'll say Census.
I'll say Census, like the government.
>> Does it have a spot for
front-end developments?
>> They have software developers, so
I hope they'll give that out
to back-end, full-stack.
But I will say Census is
more statistically relevant.
>> That's true.
>> Versus Glassdoor when
you're just cherry picking.
>> That's true.
>> A lot of your hosts and
articles that you're reading off.
So again, it's hard, it still depends.
So if you have further
questions on full-stack,
we actually had a webcast
on full-stack last week,
so I highly suggest you
take a look at that.
And if you have further
questions on that sort of stuff,
we can definitely post your
questions on the forum and
we'll find a full-stack coach
who get you the resources and
information that you need.
>> I have a couple more questions.
Do you want to move on or
actually address these quick?
>> Let's move on a little bit.
>> Okay.
We'll come back to
the questions in a little bit.
>> Yeah.
All right, so that's the front-end.
So again, take away from the front-end,
we have design and we have frameworks.
So, when you think about your front-end,
think about design first,
how you're going to lay out everything,
and how from a general picture,
a bigger level,
how does everything look?
How do you plan on everything looking
out, because then you could then figure
out the technology, the frameworks
that can help you drive that design.
Now, let's move on to the back-end.
And, if you're going to walk away
from the back-end, one lesson or
one thing that we should all walk away
with is this is crucial question.
Will our content be static or dynamic?
What does that mean, static, dynamic?
And static is just the information will
not change, depending on any user.
Like, I just want to just write a blog,
write an article.
That article will never change.
You may, of course, you may edit, proof
read it, add some addendums to it, but
for the most part it will not change
much throughout the life of that blog or
the life of the article.
So, do you need technology,
do you need programming
interface servers to
actually change that article
depending on whatever inputs,
whatever factors?
Probably not, because you
write an article, it's static.
It doesn't change, it's not dynamic.
So, if all of your content will
indeed be static then that
makes the next questions
a whole lot easier to answer.
Because these questions
will involve in how
much horsepower and how much dynamic.
>> Interactivity, yeah.
>> Interactivity,
that you need from the back-end.
because, again, if it's static,
you could just literally write your
code in HTML and
then just find a simple web host.
>> Yeah.
>> Actually a host.server.
Yeah, host your files on a server,
and then you're done.
That you don't need any
other support technology.
Now, if the question is dynamic
then that will actually help
drive us further on how much
dynamic power do we need?
So let's move on.
So, that's a first crucial question,
is it static or dynamic?
because basically, we're going to
talk about three things now.
Let me look at my notes.
Basically, we're going to
talk about server hosting.
Now, where can we find a server
that could host our web pages?
And there's tons of them.
And what type of hosting is there,
is provided?
And the type of services,
the type of dynamic services, or
even static services that we need,
like does our back-end server need
to put in and accept API requests?
Or does the back-end server need to host
a database as well access some data for
a user and then give it to that user?
Example, a banking website.
I'll tell you right now,
a banking website has a very,
very powerful back-end server.
Because guess what,
there's a lot of money involved.
It has to access very secure
databases to access your money,
and it has a ton of services for
you to be able to go in ahead and
change your address, do a wire transfer,
withdraw some money,
deposit some money, add in a check,
schedule recurring charges.
That's a lot of services, and
that requires a back-end technology
data that has to be very secure.
It has to be very robust.
>> Has to be secure,
also has to be easily usable.
>> Exactly, for the back-end,
also for the front-end people.
So basically, usually,
you have a front-end person who takes
care of all the front-end stuff.
And then he or she will talk with the
back-end person who takes care of all
the databases and they talk with another
and say, hey, what's your API endpoint?
And, I need some documentation of
when I set off my AJAX request,
sent off my requests on my front-end
to be able to get the data I need for
what I need to do.
So, there's constant communication
between the front and
the back-end person.
If that person's not a full-stack
person who's doing both.
And, the third thing I'm going to be
talking about is the technology stack.
I'll say it's an important
thing to understand.
It's also an important thing to
understand the vocabulary at the lingo
when we're talking with
other web developers.
Okay, so, server hosting.
There's three Categories of hosting.
One, I call this easy hosting.
This is a combination of free
hosting and shared hosting.
Now let me backtrack and
let's define what hosting is.
>> Yeah.
>> Hosting is basically, I create my
web page on my own local computer,
but now I want to be
able to go ahead and
upload my files so everyone else
can access on the Internet.
Usually it's a big pain if you
only want to do it ourself.
If we want to hook up our own local
server in our own house to serve,
which, you could still do that.
But we don't recommend it.
That's more for an advanced user to
actually set up their own hosting.
>> Also more prone to error and
rainstorms.
>> Rainstorms, your cable shuts off,
or your computer.
Your computer shuts down,
well then guess what your server, no one
will be able to access your website.
And if you want to make some money off
your website it's good to actually
hostess out and find a host to actually.
You pay them because you
pay them a nominal fee for
them to take care of the servers.
If the servers go down,
you have someone 24 seven,
365 days a week to make sure that
the servers are always running.
And they also have the bandwidth that
you need because basically your own
little internet provider on,
in your house won't be enough
to move say serve thousands of people
who may be accessing your website.
So that's the advantage of the hosting.
So basically recommend five hosts yeah.
>> So
actually somebody question about that.
>> Yeah.
>> You just answered it is great and
there are some, there are some.
I feel like there's some places where
you can host for free aren't there?
>> Yeah.
Host for free, but then they force
you to either host their own ads.
>> Ads, right.
So you have ad-supported hosting.
>> Yeah, that's ad-supported hosting.
So the ads you don't necessarily
want them to show well, l tough luck
because they'll force you to host
those ads instead of you paying.
And I recommend that you
just go ahead and pay.
Pay them if you want more
streamlined user experience.
Yeah, there's some great.
Smaller hosting sites,
we'll go to that later,
but Squarespace I think-
>> Yeah.
>> Is it free?
>> Squarespace?
>> I don't know if they're free.
>> Is it free?
>> I don't think so.
>> Okay.
>> For sure GitHub is free.
>> GitHub is free.
>> Yeah, the github.io page is free.
>> Yeah.
>> That is completely free for
developers, and if just want
to host your own website and
if it's static perfect.
>> Yeah.
>> I actually personally will
do that myself if I were to just
host static web pages.
I don't need to do any,
I don't need any backend support.
Yeah I'll just going to GitHub.
>> Cool.
>> Push my changes and there to go.
So that's easy hosting, and
that's really good for static web pages.
Now once you level up,
let's assume that we need some more
technology to create a forum host or
like a formation page,
like Reddit or any other forum star.
You gotta see discussion forums or
even say a banking website, right?
>> Yeah.
>> You're going to need some
more horsepower.
You're going to need to actually
have access to the server itself and
actually install and
set up all the software that's needed
to actually host the server, and
host the web pages like virtual private
server or a dedicated hosting site.
This is actually for people.
These are peoples full time jobs,
like these Linux administrator and
these are people who actually
set up things for other people.
This can be a full time job for
a lot of people and
if your if you feel like you
want to get into this space and
learn how to do that and
by all means I encourage you.
And yeah there's tons of the tutorials
out there to learn how to set up
a server like a web server like using
Apache and setting that up in Linux.
Basically that's the second tier and
if this is the cover you need
to set up everything yourself.
All they give you is just a server
a box some were In the world.
>> Arizona.
>> Arizona, New York whatever and
you have route access,
you have access to that
server 24/7 remotely and
you'll go to type in a lot of basically
a lot of terminal commands to be
able to actually set up the server FTP,
upload your files to the server and
just be set everything
>> And
that of course that cost money
because you're basically renting
a server,
a whole computer too by chance and
this actually if you having more
than a couple thousand people,
yeah that's when you started
needing some more horsepower.
>> Yeah.
To actually serve.
And then third,
this is called Platform as a Service.
This is actually a combination
of Easy Hosting and
also dedicated,
I'll say Virtual Private Server.
I must say.
And if you're a programmer,
your developer and you want to be
able to create a forum or
a create a banking website.
You need some backend
support that actually
handles all the database requests.
Well that means that you've got or set
up some things up yourself or actually
just use a platform as a service where
they actually tell you, okay we're
going to set up everything for you or
you need to do is just upload your code.
This is google app engine, and
so for the people who are at.
At the stage four what you're using
is called a platform as a service and
hosting and that's that's call.
Yes that's hosting your you host it.
And yet, for one day you have like
this basically I think a gigabyte
worth of free bandwidth.
Anything else and
they'll start charging you.
>> I know that.
>> Yeah, so like it's free to
just play around to use for
the first yeah for a few thousand.
>> Yeah.
>> People who will access it,
it will be free and that's a platform
as a service where you just
upload your Python code
your back end code.
Which we'll talk about next
in our back end technology.
They take care of all the server set up,
you don't need to even touch a terminal
they take care of all
the data base set up and
they take care of the redundancy
the redundancies that's needed.
All you need to do this,
upload your code focus on
developing your application and
then that's it you pay them a nominal
fee and if you blow up that's great.
>> You scale up.
>> You just scale up and
you know hopefully if you make
more money of the new bill to pay
off more of the server costs.
>> Created Strout.
>> Yeah.
Great so that's server hosting.
So depends on again, the question of
is a static is a dynamic content?
What level of dynamic
content do I really need?
What level of horsepower do I need for
my website?
>> Mike, before we move on could
we answer a couple questions?
>> Go ahead.
>> One question about
the night degree itself.
Is this niche certifications in this,
or just experience only?
For what we're talking about?
>> I'm not quite sure.
>> Yeah I think.
>> What is this?
>> Yeah yeah yeah.
>> I think this.
>> I think he is talking
about front-end and
backend development.
>> That's what there
are two nano degrees called
the front-end nano degree and
then the full stack nano degree.
They're actually You'll dive into
detail about develop the front end and
the back end yeah.
Yeah I really suggest you just
if you're more interested,
investigate the full stack and
the front end Nanodegree to go to get
to figure out how you should do this.
Now all these how because what
we're tell you is what and why.
What we're not going to cover is
the how, that that takes a whole-
>> That's the degree.
That's the whole certification
process for you to take.
So hopefully that will help guide you.
>> And as far as getting experience,
you can do it sort of on your
own start building websites.
That's really the best way to gain
experience without being in a job,
and yeah.
So, let's see who else.
Cover more questions on the framework.
Is Ruby on Rails considered
a front end or back end tool?
>> Select that.
>> Ruby on Rails is a backend tool.
It serves websites, but
it doesn't handle the HTML,
the actual designing of the HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript.
It's just basically like your
Python that you're learning and
stage four to serve your websites.
>> Cool stuff.
>> Ruby is the programming language and
Rails is the frame work.
>> Okay I get it.
>> WebApp 2
is your frame work that
we're using Python.
>> Interesting.
>> As far as the ads go.
Yes, the sites have ads everywhere
because they want to make
a lot of money.
So it just depends how many ads
do you want to put on your page.
It's how much money you're
going to make off of them.
Also the user experience.
How much how say,
my question is, how well do you
want the user experience to be?
And I understand the ads are necessary
if you want to make some money.
It's just that you can
still be smart about it.
You can still try to integrate those
ads into your website and then,
as far as like ads that the hosting
company puts on a web page.
You have less control over how many
go on and it depends on the hosting
company as to whether you can
control where to put those ads.
But then again just depends.
>> Good question,
there's a lot of questions today.
>> A lot of really practical questions.
So Connor asks, does the use of
frameworks reduce the need to know
the DOM like the back of your palm?
Yes.
So mapping everything
out is a way to reduce
memorizing everything.
And it's so you have everything
on one page you can refer to this
when you're going through and
building your website.
You are like, okay,
I'm going to start with my top most div,
like this is that box and then I'm
going to start with the header div and
that's this box, so
when you go back to it your like.
This divs within that div and
you can find it in your code.
You don't have to memorize things or
dig really too deep and
it saves a lot of time.
So great question.
>> Yeah I'll say don't
depend on the front row so
much they will become a crux.
I tell you right now if
a lot of a lot of people say they know,
say, the front end stuff.
I've heard this talk among Mike and
some other front end people.
A lot of people say they know JCORE but
they don't know JavaScript.
That should be reversed, actually.
>> Interesting.
>> If they say if you study enough
JCORE, you can basically
do a lot of stuff.
With JCORE, but then if the need
arises that this framework
doesn't quite do what it can do,
because it's just a framework,
it's just a way for you to do things
in some sort of idealized environment.
You have to resort to
actual learning JavaScript.
Knowing the actual JavaScript and
knowing how to access the DOM in
JavaScript, and
know how to access those notes.
So I will say, yeah it does reduce
the need for you to know the DOM or
the document objects models like the
back of your hand, and highly recommend.
I use frameworks all the time for
myself, but you should not depend on it
too much, or else it will be a crux.
And if you're trying to find a job
in front end or back end, what
developer they expect you to
know the DOM and they expect
you to know how to manipulate the DOM
using just plain straight JavaScript.
>> Straight JavaScript, CSS, and HTML.
>> Yeah, good point.
>> Mm-hm.
All right.
>> All right, let's move on.
>> Let's move on.
So the next thing that
I'm going to talk about is-
>> Services.
>> Basically, this is based
like once we've chosen our host
our type of host we need to figure out
what is it exactly that we need to do?
What's this service?
When I say service I mean what is it
that does the back end server supposed
to take in from the front end and
was this supposed output?
If there's a running theme in this issue
of the programming now degree is it is
what you always need to ask the question
what's the input and what's the output?
What the input to the server like
what are the what's that type of
information that are back in
service getting from the front end?
Okay, this is the type
of information I need.
Let's draw this down, let's say,
a banking website site.
I need to know your account information.
I need to know your login information.
I need to know,
how much money do you want to transfer?
All those little inputs, and
then at the output, okay.
What's my output?
What am I producing?
What am I trying to do?
And let's say for
a banking website, for my output I
most likely need to access some sort of
database to change that account balance.
If someone needs to get
me an input withdrawal or
deposit $200,
I need to basically plus one.
When a person logs into my website I
need to process their password and
compare it to a password database and
make sure that is correct.
If it's correct then I let them
log in and send them a valid cookie and
then they'll be able to log in..
So those are the big things
that you need to consider.
What are your big services that
your back end is trying to do?
Again if your back end is just
sort of static web pages,
then that's really the one service
just serving the web page.
The input is a request
from the browser and
the output is it will just
send you the HTML code.
That's your input and output for
your backend for a static webpage.
Now, dynamics, there's a lot of things
that's happening and then you're
going to need a programming language
to actually help process the inputs and
outputs, which is actually next
things called the Technology Stack.
So we have three things in
the Technology Stack so
the first thing is some people
mentioned programming languages.
What is the program language
that we want to use?
What's that basic technology?
>> Yeah.
>> You're learning Python.
In stage four and
that's your of course stack.
That's your core technology that you'll
using to process inputs and outputs, but
then there's a lot of other programming
languages that other people used too
called Java, .NET, Ruby,
Node.JS, PHP, a lot of people.
I'll see PHP ASP and
PHP is actually really old.
[CROSSTALK] It's actually is
a server side technology you
run code on the server and
then it's a spits out the HTML.
Again what's your step what's
your programing language?
Which was once you figure that out.
You could then figure out,
okay depending on my services,
what's my database?
There are two big types of databases
right now they should really just
need to think about as
conversational databases.
mySQL, PostGresSQL,
those are two free databases that
you can install and your server and use.
And then there's non relational
databases called NoSQL,
MongoDB, Hadoop, Cassandra.
And those are other type of
databases that do not depend
on putting your data into
a traditional spreadsheet-like table.
Then, based on your experience and
based on what you need, you may choose,
let's say, a MongoDB server.
Because you just want to
read things really fast, and
you just want to be able to go ahead and
just store information like in objects.
Then that's what we're using
in Google's Datastore.
It's NoSQL type of database.
Course is a more relational database.
And now, relational databases,
they're old school.
They are older, but they're very
reliable, and they're very normalized.
Meaning that they actually,
if you organize your data very well,
it works very well, and
the performance is decent as well.
Though once you scale up, relational
databases start hitting a wall.
And especially if you try
to do joins in your tables.
It gets really slow if you're trying
to do outer joins, inner joins,
or anything like that,
like off a 2 million record database.
Things start slowing down.
So I will say, yeah.
Depends on what you're familiar with and
what type of database
system that you want.
And, like how are you going to scale up?
You may even use a combination.
One part I'm going to use NoSQL,
MongoDB to host my user accounts.
And then another part, relational,
I'm going to use that to store in
the rest of the information I have
about my users so well, it depends.
There's most tradeoffs on relational and
NoSQL database.
And then the next is
Server Operating System.
Now this is really what
you're familiar with.
A lot of servers operate on Linux, but
there is a sizable number of
servers that operate on Windows.
And why should you care?
Well, it just makes it
apparent that you need to
know the type of technology
that you can work with.
Say, if it's a Linux,
then expect to work a lot in
the terminal, the command prompt.
But with Linux, you have a lot of free
software that you can just install on
your computer and run with it.
Versus Windows, most likely you're going
to use a Windows software called IIS.
>> It's is all proprietary.
Internet Information Server
is called Microsoft IIS.
I forgot the acronym what it stands for,
but yet it's all for proprietary.
>> Is it INS?
>> I think it is IIS.
Look that up an update our notes,
but yeah it's all proprietary.
Other servers Oracle, HP, Dell,
they may have their own special system.
But again, it depends on how much
you're familiar with your server and
how flexible do you
want your server to be?
So we're about the end of our
little presentation here so
let's just have a little summary here.
So John, can you just summarize
the front-end a little bit?
>> Yeah, so we covered the big ideas
in design about making a website look
good and work well, which is laying
out all the boxes that you have
either on paper or some sort of
graphics program on your computer.
We laid out the user interface.
So, where do you want
the users to login?
Where you want the users
to post comments?
We talked about which boxes
you want to put those and
what sort of technologies you
want to connect to those.
And we also talked a little bit about
graphics about whether you want to
design things in-house, outsource them.
And if you decide to design them
in-house, what sort of things do you
want think about as far as ease of
looking at it in terms of contrast,
and how to lay that out in your
in your sketch and fire frame.
We also covered JavaScript and
CSS frameworks.
And these are sort of pre bundled
software that you can use
to help your development move faster and
work better and
work with a lot more capabilities
than you probably even knew existed.
And that sort of wrapped up all the
things that you want to think about when
you're planning the front-end
side of your web page.
And then we sort of
transitioned into Back-End.
Yeah, so three things that you
need to know about the Back-End.
How are you going to host your content?
Is your content static, or dynamic?
That will really drive the rest of
your decisions on trying to figure out
the Back-End part of your website,
the type of services.
Do you need a database,
do you need to have API end points,
do you need to have user accounts
like to allow people to log in?
Do you need all of that?
What's up with things that
will to Surat actually do?
And then last is the technology stack.
Really, what the programming language is
what are frameworks that you're going to
use, what type of
databases will you use?
And also what type of environment server
operating system environment will
you use?
because all developers will actually
asked you so what's your stack?
What's your technology stack?
And, I'll give you an example,
a classic stack is called Map.
Linux, Apache, MySQL,
PHP, so I'm using Linux.
I'm using Apache.
Apache is the software to actually-
>> On a server?
>> Actually, serves the website.
I'm using MySQL.
That's my database.
I'm using PHP is my
programming language.
A lot of people to say they love Pearl,
you can use Pearl.
You can also use Python too.
>> Perl, yeah.
>> As your text stack as well.
Another text stack is model database
express framework angler JS.
And is no JS, no JS is your back end.
It's actually written in JavaScript so
you're using JavaScript actually serve
your web pages as well in addition
to actually using JavaScript to
manipulate your web pages
from the front end.
>> Talking about manipulating web pages,
there is a question actually about what
that means to manipulate
the DOM through JavaScript.
>> Right, so the DOM basically
is called the doc object model.
And it's basically you can
think of a tree, right?
It's like an abstract tree where
you have elements belonging
to other elements in your HTML.
And if you think about it,
without JavaScript, there is no way for
you to manipulate the DOM or
change the DOM live.
The only way for you to change
the relationship or change want,
like add in a paragraph, right into
a division, there is no way for
you to do that without actually
having to open up your editor,
edit the HTML code, and
then reload the webpage.
>> Can't do that every single time.
>> You can't do it every single time,
especially for use.
But let's that say that you want to
program something interactive or
you want to dynamically add in
a paragraph in the website, you will
use JavaScript actually manipulate
the DOM to make sure you manipulate any
actually add in a paragraph
inside the web site itself live.
So when the person
loads up your web page,
they may not have to paragraph insert.
But then if they do, if they click
a button, then the button will actually
launch a JavaScript function that
will actually go ahead, and insert
a paragraph element inside some sort
of a div elementary container element.
So that's what we mean when
we say manipulate the DOM.
>> Yeah, sounds great.
This is a really nice diagram that
really sort of pulls together
everything that you can think
about planning a website.
>> Yeah.
Thank you, thank you.
>> So again, these notes will be posted,
hopefully, by tonight or tomorrow.
So they will be posted
on the discussion forum.
So please just log onto the discussion
forums and look at the categories and
then look for
the Office Hour Notes category.
And you'll be able to go ahead and
look at our notes.
Highlight them, read them,
reflect on them, digest them.
And then yeah,
if you have any further questions on
whatever we presented today,
please post it in the discussion forums.
Thank you very much for your time.
>> Thanks so much for coming.
>> All right, thank you.
Bye.
>> Bye.
[BLANK_AUDIO]